WELCOME BACK TO CANADA'S
PRESIDENT SAYS CONSTITUTIONAL
ORDER HAS BEEN MAINLY RESTORED
IN ALL REGIONS OF HIS COUNTRY.
HIS WORDS COME AFTER ANTI
GOVERNMENT PROTESTS SWEPT
ACROSS THE NATION THIS WEEK,
LEAVING DOZENS DEAD ACCORDING
TO STATE MEDIA.
THE PRESIDENT WENT ON TO SAY
THAT THE ANTI CARE OPERATION IS
NOW UNDERWAY AND SECURITY
FORCES ARE NOW WORKING HARD.
CNN'S, NICK ROBERTSON HAS MORE
ON THE CRACKDOWN, AND ITS
AFTERMATH.
>> ON ALL MATTERS STREETS, IN A
HARD TO VERY FINDS SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS, AN UGLY OVERNIGHT
CRACKDOWN.
PEOPLE SCREAM AND SCURRY FOR
COVER.
PANIC, AS WELL AS BULLETS IN
THE AIR.
THEY ARE DEAD THEY ARE DEAD, HE
SAYS.
THE MOTION'S BODY, TO STEADILY
REACH STRETCHED OUT OF THE
FREEZING GROUND.
IN THE SAME CITY, THE COUNTRY'S
BIGGEST PROTESTERS FOUGHT
PRINCE BATTLES WITH UNIFORM
FORCES --
CASUALTIES ARE MULLET-ING ON
BOTH SIDES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT APPEARING TO
GAIN THE UPPER HAND, WITH THE
REST AND KILLINGS.
POLICE CLEARLY TOOK DEADLY
ACTION OVERNIGHT.
DESCRIBING AN AS YET,
UNVERIFIED SHADOWY TO SHOOT
FIRST AND ASK QUESTIONS LATER,
CRACKDOWN.
>> LAST NIGHT EXTREMIST FORCES
ATTEMPTED TO FORM STORM THE
ADMINISTER BUILDINGS AND THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE CITY
OF ALMIGHTY.
DOZENS OF ATTACKERS WERE
ELIMINATED AND THEIR IDENTITIES
ARE STILL BEING VERIFIED.
>> THE MAN --
IN ALL MATTIE'S APPARENT
TESTIMONY TO THE FEROCITY OF
THE BATTLES FOUGHT.
WITHOUT OFFERING PROOF THAT THE
KAZAKH PRESIDENT CLAIMING
PROTESTERS ARE FOREIGN BACKED
TERRORISTS.
THEY OFTEN USED TROPE TO
DEFLECT BLAME.
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS ALSO
REPEATING.
I CHARACTERIZATION REJECTED BY
PROTESTERS.
>> WE ARE NEITHER THUGS NOR
TERRORISTS, THIS WOMAN SAYS.
THE ONLY THING FLOURISHING HERE
IS CORRUPTION.
>> WE WANT THE TRUTH, THIS
PROTESTER SAYS.
THE GOVERNMENT IS RICH.
BUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE HERE HAVE
LOANS TO PAY.
WE HAVE OUR PAIN, AND WE WANT
TO SHARE IT.
BUT TRUTH, AND FACTS HERE ARE
IN SHORT SUPPLY.
THE INTERNET DOUBT FOR A 2ND
DAY.
RESIDENTS REPORTING A SCARY
QUIET.
BRAVING GOVERNMENT WARNINGS TO
STAY INDOORS, TO GO OUT AND
SEARCH FOR OPEN SHOPS TO BUY
ESSENTIALS.
>> RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA,
REPORTING HEAVILY ON ALLEGEDLY
RAMPANT LOOTING, BY SOME
PROTESTERS.
AS WELL AS HIGHLIGHTING
VIOLENCE AGAINST CATHOLIC LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AS PART OF A REGIONAL SECURITY
AGREEMENT, RUSSIAN PARATROOPERS
BEGAN DEPLOYING TO GUARD STATE
AND MILITARY FACILITIES.
FOR 4 CONSECUTIVE DAYS OF
PROTESTS, GUNFIRE AND
EXPLOSIONS, STILL ROCKING
ALMIGHTY.
NICK ROBINSON, CNN, MOSCOW.
WELL I WANT TO BRING IN DANA,
CRONENBERG AND WHO'S --
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF SOCIAL
HAJI AND UNIVERSITY OF
CAMBRIDGE, GOOD TO HAVE YOU
WITH US PROFESSOR.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> SO, WAS THE CATALYST FOR THE
PROTESTS.
BUT IT'S FAR FROM THE ONLY
REASON FOR THIS CAN DISCONTENT.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS, HIGH WAGES ARE
LOW, THE PANDEMIC INDUCED
RECESSION.
HOW TOUGH IS LIFE RIGHT NOW FOR
PEOPLE IN CAT EXTEND?
WHERE IS THIS ARREST AND LONG
TIME COMING?
IT DEFINITELY HAS BEEN
EMBARRASSING FOR A WHILE BUT
GAS PRICES, IS THE TRIGGER FOR
THIS.
IT'S THE INITIAL FUEL THAT THE
PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN MUCH DEEPER
FEET IN THE SCIENTISTS, AND
HAPPEN SLOWLY BUT SURELY BOTH
THE SOCIAL SECURITY.
BUT THEN WE'VE BEEN SEEING THAT
WHAT WE'VE BEEN POKING ABOUT'S
MODERNIZATION.
AND THE PROMISE IS, OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ORDINARY FOLD
ESPECIALLY IN THE LOWER --
CANNOT REALLY SEE THOSE FOCUSED
OF BEING IMPLEMENTED IN DAILY
LIVES SO I THINK THAT WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW THIS RESPONSE
TO THAT LACK OF SOCIAL SECURITY
AND.
>> AND HOW MUCH OF A PROBLEM IS
AND --
THEY'VE HAD SOME DESCRIBE AS
ENDEMIC.
>> YES DEFINITELY, AND THEN YOU
SEPARATE THE DIFFERENT LEVELS
ARE LARGELY.
OUR FEAR OF PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
THERE WHO ARE WHERE IN THE
PUBLIC.
ESPECIALLY OF LAVISH AND THE
TYPE OF --
AND THERE'S ALSO EVERY DAY
CORRUPTION ON THIS BUT THAT'S
BASICALLY PART OF EVERYDAY LIFE.
IT CAUSED A LOT OF --
THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING ARE
CAUSED BY THIS SYSTEM THAT IS
KILLED AND THEY ALSO WANT TO
CONNECT IT OMICRON CORRUPTION.
IT'S BOUND TO THE REGIME OF
WHATEVER PAUL COLLEAGUES
DESCRIBING IT AS SYSTEMATIC.
IT'S CALLING IT A SYSTEM!
IT'S A REGIME THAT CAUSES --
IT >> SO DIANA, RUSSIA'S
VERSION OF NATO THE C S T O.
THE GROUP OF FORMER SOVIET
COUNTRIES.
ITS MILITARIES AND TROOPS ARE
ON THE GROUND.
I'M WONDERING WHAT PUTIN STANDS
TO GAIN FROM GETTING INVOLVED?
THAT HE SIMPLY WANT STABILITY?
OR IS THERE PERHAPS AN ULTERIOR
MOTIVE?
>> I THINK, IN MY OPINION, I'M
VERY CAUTIOUS WITH THIS
SPECULATIONS ESPECIALLY THIS
EARLY WE'RE GONNA STILL HAVE TO
SEE HOW IT PANS.
OUT DEFINITELY, I THINK ONE OF
THE MAIN MESSAGES RIGHT NOW IS
POLITICALLY FORMIDABLY --
IT IS THE POSSIBILITY.
I'M NOT BASING IT ON MY
COLLEAGUES THAT OUR SPECIALISTS
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT IF THE RUSSIANS THE
BIGGEST ALLY IN THE REGION.
IT'S THE BIGGEST COUNTRY.
AND --
TERRITORIAL BORDER WITH RUSSIA.
SO DEFER THE FIRST COST WILL BE
DID STABILITY IN THE COUNTRY.
NOBODY WANTS KAZAKHSTAN TO BE
THE HOT SPOT RIGHT NOW.
>> YES.
SO THIS IS A COUNTRY KNOWN TO
CRACK DOWN ON DISSENT.
HOW UNPRECEDENTED ARE THESE
PROTESTS?
>> THE PROTESTS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND THEY HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE COUNTRY FOR
ELISE THE DECADE.
WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAVES OF --
WESTERN KAVA WE'RE SEEING THE
2017 --
[INAUDIBLE] THANKFULLY THERE
ARE ANY CASUALTIES.
FINALLY IN 2019, DOCTOR MOLE --
THE POLITICAL PARTY SAID THAT
IS FORCED AND CREATED A NUMBER
OF SOCIAL MOVEMENT IN ALMIGHTY.
BUT THIS FOCUS IS ON --
IT'S ALSO UNPRECEDENTED IN
TERMS OF ACTUAL VIOLENCE.
AND THOSE ELEMENTS AS A RESULT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
WITH ALL THE TRAGEDIES
UNFORTUNATELY THE CIVILIANS,
THE GOVERNMENT CALLS AND
TERRORISTS.
>> I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT, DIANA, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HAS REFERRED TO THESE
PROTESTS AS FOREIGN,
TERRORISTS.
BUT WHAT AUDIENCE IS HE PLAYING
TO?
>> I THINK THOSE DOMESTIC AND
--
AND ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
HERE IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
INTERNET FOR THE PAST FEW DAYS.
THE PEOPLE ARE LARGELY DISTANT
FORMED.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT --
IS THAT PEOPLE COMPLETELY
DISORIENTED.
THEIR ACTIONS.
IMAGINE BEING IN THE CITY WHERE
YOU HAVE TO BE ADHERE TO ALL OF
THE TRUE THINGS HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
BECAUSE IT IS VERY DIGITALLY
CONNECT TO THE NATION.
BUT PEOPLE WAS LIVING MESSAGES
AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT NOW THE ONLY RESORTED TO
INFORMATION IS BASICALLY STATE
MEDIA.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FEELING
VERY ANXIOUS, BECAUSE THE TRUST
ME IS VERY.
LOW THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON WHEN THEY SPEAK.
--
IT'S TORTURE NOT KNOWING WHAT'S
GOING ON.
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY, THE
AUDIENCE IS BOTH DOMESTIC AND
FOREIGN BECAUSE IT JUSTIFIES
THEIR ACTIONS.
THERE WILL BE VIOLENCE IN TERMS
OF ECONOMICS --
WE'RE GOING TO ANALYZE IN THE
COMING DAYS FOR SURE.
IT'S A VERY ALARMING FOR LOCALS,
AND I FEEL FOR THE RESIDENTS
THAT ARE VERY ANXIOUS AND
SCARED RIGHT NOW.
>> YES,